en el vídeo anterior nos dieron una
función de varias variables efe
y nos pedían que encontráramos y
clasificamos
todos los puntos críticos de esta
función verdad entonces recordemos que
un punto crítico es justamente donde el
gradiente de nuestra función se anula es
decir es el vector cero verdad y
nosotros en realidad hallamos cuatro
puntos críticos y aquí están los cuatro
puntos críticos el 0 0 0 - 2 raíz de 3 1
y menos raíz de 3,1 ahora el siguiente
paso es clasificarlos y para eso
requerimos el criterio de la segunda
derivada así que voy a copiar y pegar
las derivadas
las primeras derivadas que son estas
a copiar y pegar las abajo para poder
tener espacio y trabajar muy bien
entonces vamos a copiar estás derivadas
muy bien entonces de hecho no
necesitamos esta simplificación solo
vamos a dejarlo así para que tengamos un
buen espacio para trabajar muy bien
entonces lo que necesitamos para aplicar
el criterio de la segunda derivada es
justamente calcular todas las derivadas
de segundo orden entonces empecemos
primero con la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de x ambas veces entonces
tenemos que derivar esta expresión con
respecto de x y aquí ya es una constante
verdad entonces tendremos 6 porque por
la derivada de x respecto de x que es 1
- la derivada de 6x que es 6 bien ahí
tenemos nuestra primera derivada ahora
derivamos dos veces a efe con respecto a
y verdad ambas veces entonces sería
derivar esta expresión con respecto de
esto es una constante entonces al
derivar es cero verdad es una constante
para fines de derivar con respecto de y
si derivamos esto con respecto de james
nos da menos seis por ye verdad y luego
al derivar esto de aquí es menos 6 menos
6 y finalmente tenemos que calcular la
derivada parcial mixta verdad primero
respecto de x y luego respecto de g y
por supuesto que en realidad puede ser
primero respecto de yale luego respecto
de x aquí en realidad tenemos puros
polinomios es algo que se puede hacer
pero vamos a derivar ahora esta
expresión con respecto de y muy bien
entonces aquí es la variable 6x es una
constante entonces al derivar esto
simplemente nos da
x y esto es una constante para fines de
derivar respecto de iu y al derivar lo
nos da 0 entonces estas tres son las
derivadas parciales de segundo orden así
que vamos ahora a borrar esto y pongamos
la expresión necesaria que tenemos que
analizar para utilizar el criterio de la
segunda derivada verdad
recordemos que necesitamos calcular la
segunda derivada de f con respecto de x
ambas veces multiplicarlo por la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de ambas
veces y luego restarle el cuadrado de la
segunda derivada de f pero la la
derivada mixta cierto esta es la
expresión que necesitamos así que vamos
a ver cuánto vale esto en cada uno de
nuestros puntos críticos entonces
digamos para el punto cero cero
necesitamos
evaluar esto cuando es igual a cero
verdad entonces tendremos 6 por 0 es 0
menos 6 es menos 6
ahora esto evaluado en 0 sería menos 6
por 0 0 menos 6 es otra vez menos 6 y
luego restamos esto evaluado en x igual
a 0 al cuadrado pero por supuesto que
esto es 0 al cuadrado entonces esto es
menos 6 x menos 6 que son 36 que de
hecho es un valor positivo pero bueno
luego hacemos el análisis de cada uno de
los puntos críticos que hay entonces
ahora vamos a hacerlo en cero coma menos
2 entonces aquí sería 6 x menos dos
menos 6 6 por menos 2 es menos 12 menos
6 nos da menos 18 menos 18 muy bien
ahora aquí sería menos 6 x menos 2
verdad aquí serían menos serían más 12
menos 6 serían menos sería 12 menos 6 es
6 verdad y luego restamos 0 al cuadrado
otra vez porque x es cero
entonces tenemos menos 18 por 6 es menos
6 por 8 son 48 llevamos 46 por 1 son 6 y
4 son 10 son menos 108 en realidad el
valor no importa porque lo que importa
es que es negativo muy bien ahora
hagamos con este siguiente punto crítico
que es raíz de 3,1
muy bien entonces vamos a borrar esta
parte y ahora vamos a analizarlo con
raíz de 3
31 y entonces tendríamos 6 por el valor
de que sería uno menos 6 entonces
tendríamos 6 x menos 6 es 0 verdad ahora
bien si lo hacemos aquí abajo vamos a
borrar esta parte para no confundirnos
verdad entonces si nosotros ahora
evaluamos con ye igual aún no tendríamos
menos 6 por 1 menos 6 y esto nos da
menos 12 verdad esto es 0 x menos 2 en
realidad no importa que era esto vamos a
multiplicar por 0 y nos dará 0 entonces
lo único que nos falta es restar las
derivadas parciales mixtas verdad
entonces aquí sería 6 x raíz de 3 porque
x es raíz de 3 entonces esto sería 6 x
raíz de 3 elevado al cuadrado verdad
entonces esto sería 0 y tendríamos que
restar 36 por 3 verdad 36 por 3 son 108
108 en realidad no importa verdad otra
vez lo que va a importar es que sea
negativo y ahora qué pasaría si tenemos
menos raíz de 3 con 1 verdad entonces
otra vez aquí tendríamos 6 por 16 que
sería 0 verdad aquí tendríamos menos 6
por 1 menos 6 que en realidad sería
menos 12 otra vez y tendríamos menos 6
más bien sería menos raíz bueno
tendremos que sustituir con x igual a
menos raíz de 3 verdad entonces aquí
sería menos 6 raíz de 3 y no importa en
realidad porque vamos a elevar al
cuadrado y esto será exactamente igual a
menos 108 verdad que son 36 por 3 ok
entonces si nos damos cuenta ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es analizar qué es
lo que nos dice el criterio de la
segunda derivada verdad nos dice que si
esta expresión es mayor que 0 entonces
vamos a tener un máximo vamos a tener un
mínimo y si esto es menor que cero
entonces vamos a tener un punto silla
puntos y allá entonces de esto podemos
observar que sólo este este punto
crítico es un punto máximo o mínimo
verdad y de hecho podríamos saber si es
un máximo mínimo porque la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de x cuando
evaluamos en el punto crítico que 0 0
verdad en realidad es menos 6 eres traer
a este es el valor de la segunda
derivada respecto de x y eso es negativo
quiere decir que la concavidad es hacia
abajo verdad y entonces tendríamos un
punto máximo verdad entonces la
concavidad se ve más o menos así y
entonces aquí tendríamos un
máximo ahora bien en todos estos en
estos tres restantes tendremos valores
negativos lo cual nos dice que tenemos
puntos si la verdad es decir ni son
máximos ni son mínimos hay una dirección
en donde se pueden ver como máximos otra
donde se ven como mínimos así que la
respuesta a la pregunta original verdad
en donde nos pedían que encontráramos y
clasificáramos todos los puntos críticos
de esta función pues nosotros sabemos
que hay cuatro puntos críticos son estos
cuatro y sólo uno de ellos es un máximo
local verdad es un máximo local el punto
cero cero y eso es lo que podemos decir
incluso sin tener la gráfica de la
función como referencia bueno nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo